Speaker 1: Hey, I don't know how I missed this.
This was a few days ago. But yesterday people sent
me clips. And I do want to talk about it because
there's some interesting stuff here. I was going
to say a journalist, a man named Dan Ball from
OCN One America News had a one on one interview
with Donald Trump. Apparently, the interview was
very long and it was a bizarre interview in every
way. And I think there's a few interesting things
here. And I want to look at them with you. Let's
start with the first clip where Donald Trump again
pushes the big lie that he actually won in 2020
and then claims the country is not actually
going to survive this. Now, that is some
interest. Implications, let's listen in.
Speaker 5: You know, I don't want to be naive,
I think they're grossly incompetent.
I really do. I don't think of us
because they cheat on the elections in don't
even cheat on the elections. I mean, you look at
43000 votes were found last night. They
cheated elections. When you cheated elections,
you're out to destroy the country. They're
destroying our country. Our country will not
survive this. Our country will not survive.
Speaker 1: And what does that mean? That
the country won't survive? What it won't survive.
Joe Biden being president for four years. What
what exactly is it that the country won't survive?
And what's the timeline? And it's funny how these
hyperbola, these right wingers claim the left is
hyperbolic when the left says there is a timeline
on dealing with climate change, after which we
could hit a point of no return. They say, look
at that hyperbole. And then Trump says the country
is not going to survive this. What do you mean?
Speaker 5: Look at where they're coming from.
They're coming from Yemen. They're coming
from the Middle East. They're coming from all
countries that are very sick. Country's very sick,
very mean, nasty. They're
coming from all countries that.
Speaker 1: So Trump getting visibly confused
there. And this goes back to immigration and
the unproven idea that terrorists from Yemen and
other countries are coming through the U.S. Mexico
border. We still have no evidence of that.
It could happen that theoretically that could
happen. We have no evidence that that's actually
taking place. Trump then is saying again, his line
about the cupboards were bare when he took over,
but saying nobody could have predicted a pandemic
just could know who could have predicted it masks.
Speaker 5: We were doing what we did. All of the
coverage were bare, including the U.S. government.
The governors didn't have anything. We didn't
because nobody really ever thought a pandemic
would happen. It sounds like sort of an ancient
thing. You know, we're going back. Of course,
Speaker 1: no one could have predicted a pandemic
other than the pandemic response team, which
Trump disbanded when he became president. And
they even left a playbook about what to do in
the case of a pandemic, which they threw out
Speaker 5: in 1917, which was so bad.
Speaker 1: Oh, and Trump also mentioning the 1917
flu, which was, of course, in 1918, very, very
strange stuff. Then the interview moves on and and
hosed down ball feeds. The idea to Trump that Joe
Biden is shipping people in from the Middle East
to red states to try to cheat an election. Just
the interviewer feeding Trump conspiracy theories.
Speaker 5: Why do you think and this is another
thing, just talking about the Middle East,
why would the Biden administration want
to allow by the end of this year? By most
figures I've looked up, it's going to be one point
five, two million millions losing two million
by the end of the year. Why would you want
to do that? Are you trying to do that? And
I we're shipping them. They're shipping
them to the Midwest, the South shipping.
Speaker 1: I mean, the lesson is they're more
dehumanizing language than saying you're shipping
people like it's a computer. Red states
Speaker 5: mostly. Is this a plan
for another way to cheat at elections? So they
say it's the votes, but I don't think so. Again,
you know, I don't want to be naive.
I think they're grossly incompetent.
Speaker 1: Then it gets into the segment that that
we looked at earlier. You have to understand that
they continue to insist undocumented immigrants
from Latin America are coming here in order
to vote and cheat in elections. Undocumented
immigrants or non-citizens of any kind can't
vote. And similarly, if an asylum seeker or
refugee gets here from Afghanistan or wherever
they can't vote, they are not citizens, at least
not initially. There's a long process there. And
so this is completely and totally made up. Then
they get into the covid death toll is inflated.
It's not. They continue to repeat this one.
Speaker 5: We did a great job. In addition,
we report all of our covid at a
level that nobody in the world knows.
If somebody is dying of a heart attack and dying
of cancer and there's somewhere close to being
somebody with covid, they put it down as Cauvin.
Speaker 1: Now, that's a lie, that it is not true
that if you have a heart attack and your sister
had covid and you die from the heart attack,
they say you died of covid because
your sister. It's just not true.
Speaker 5: Believe it or not,
the doctors get more money. Yes.
Speaker 1: Can we please claim that's
also not true? What this goes back to
is the fact that it's more expensive to treat
covid patients on average. And so Medicare
pays more money to hospitals that are treating
because the hospitals incur greater costs and
are doing more things. It's a complete lie that
by just claiming someone has covid, you get more
money, that it's been widely debunked
Speaker 5: that because that has
upset me and I think millions
Speaker 1: of Americans well,
it's upset people, but it's a lie.
Speaker 5: The last 18 months,
this six hundred and twenty three thousand
death toll and the lovely. And we'll get to
CNN in a minute. The fake news, their lovely
death ticker. They had a. The last 18 months,
scaring the bejesus out of American citizens,
I think to me is treasonous, but that's
another story for another day with, well,
Speaker 1: the death counters are treason
Speaker 5: happened, by the way. And but if you
have 63 is because if she died and died from and
by the way, you look at China's real numbers
and if you look at other real numbers and.
Speaker 1: All right. So you guys
understand what's going on there.
Just an outrageous interview where it's often
just Trump telling the lies. But in this one,
the interviewer is is as much of a participant
in the lies. And then lastly, really wacky.
Trump suggests that Fox News was part of a
conspiracy to steal the election from him.
Speaker 5: And then I'm upset in Arizona. And Fox
called it early when I was leading Beck. What did
Fox know to do that? Before we wrap things
up here, I want to give a big thank you to
not only President Donald J. Trump.
Speaker 1: So how how did Fox know
to call it early? A wacky interview. And
unfortunately, people are watching OCN.
People are watching this stuff. Very, very
concerning. And the it it's too radical for
FOX News. Understand that they now criticize Fox
News as part of the problem and it's only Newsmax
and owned that will really tell you the truth.
Crazy uphill battle that we are fighting here.